Hi! Welcome to Heritage.
Here.
Okay, thanks.
Let's see, so you're returning?
I couldn't find where to return.
I need a replacement.
That's fine, I can help you here.
I'm sorry to hear you had a problem.
We'll take care of it right away.
Can you tell me what happened?
Well, I was coming off your lot and everything was fine...
When a customer is unhappy, let them tell their story.
They want to feel they've been heard and that somebody cares.
The car started shaking.
Then, ask questions that help you guide them to a solution.
So, the steering didn't feel quite right but you were still able to control the car?
Well, just barely.
Control your own emotions.
Instead of taking it personally, stay calm and focus on solving the problem.
It often helps to find something you can agree with.
This shows your willingness to work with the customer to solve the problem.
Someone should have told me that your lot would be closed.
Yes, I'm sorry about that.
We weren't expecting you back before the lot reopened.
But, it would have been good to mention it just in case.
No kidding.
Well, let me see what I can do because I'm sure we can make this right for you.